very first picture of King Charles III
His official picture post coronation
um we understand that his majesty is
pictured in his full regalia in the
throne room at Buckingham Palace he's
wearing the robe of estate she can see
there the Imperial State Crown and is
holding the sovereign's orb and
Sovereign scepter with the cross which
if you watched um the coronation here on
Sky News on Saturday you would have seen
him being handed during the coronation
ceremony he Seated on one of a pair of
uh 1902 Throne chairs that were made for
the Future King George V and Queen Mary
for use at the coronation of king Edward
VII